what i would call contemporary marketing
i see it as the thing that everybody in
this room should spend the majority of
their time on i think we need to start
having an advanced dramatically
different conversation on what team
building and leadership actually is
marketing is incredibly confused with
sales we call vaynermedia the honey
empire but the word empire is not a soft
word we're trying to build the biggest
company of all time
three to four linkedin ads a day all
different
videos pictures or words all run as ads
disproportionately this has been the
thing that i've been most emailed about
as a substantial game changer for b2b
companies to me marketing is a
conversation of ambition with all due
respect i just want you to know one
thing we are the best marketing company
in the world which means the only thing
that's about to happen is we're gonna
speed up the world knowing that your
product's a piece of crap you cannot
hire your 23 year old niece to do it
meaning
actually starting a podcast or youtube
show
around the expertise of the business
that you're in the idea of becoming the
publisher not the marketer right most
people are in sales we are sales
organizations and that's great i love
sales but marketing is the second
framework much stronger than sales
in the medium and long term
the third thing that i'm talking to you
about right now is the concept of
becoming the media company what i've
done with my career
this last tactic
because i've thrown this out in my
content different interviews and such
has been
a
major win for some small b2b mid-sized
b2b companies
and i would highly highly recommend the
people in this room that have a little
gift of gab feel like they can do this
please push yourself it really works
remember when you promised you would
never get a facebook account in 2012
humans say no
many of you when you heard about bitcoin
no the blockchain is here every contract
in the world in 15 years is gonna be on
the blockchain it's how you're gonna do
business
so what are you gonna do the same thing
you did with the internet which is fight
it until you succumbed to it and left
all that opportunity on the table you
don't like money you don't want your
family to be more stable you don't want
your business to grow you may not want
to dance on tick tock but i'm not asking
you to dance the internet is where the
real world is we spend everyone's like
the metaverse and the vr and all this
crazy stuff we're living there now do
you know how many hours are spent
looking at this and that's the point of
this talk today which is a lot's
happening
it's nice to be back on stage
there's two core things that i'm
spending a ton of time on right now and
they're pretty opposite
um one is incredibly in the weeds and
very tactical and very in the dirt which
is
what i would call contemporary marketing
whether you're in this room as b2b or
b2c
including things that wouldn't make
maybe
sense to a lot of people within the
industry of what they should be doing on
linkedin or tick tock or things of that
nature
they fascinate me
mainly because i'm a businessman right
you know i am
since i was 14 years old i've been
involved in a family business my own
business my whole life so everything
comes from the standpoint of oxygen to
pay the bills you know i was born in the
soviet union grew up in a very immigrant
family um my dad had a liquor store and
from may 18th
to that may 18 1998 until this second
that i'm standing i've had the
responsibility to make the payroll every
two weeks of every day of my life so my
framework when it comes to marketing is
actually extremely grounded in the
practicality of actually building a
business
and as i'm getting the gray hairs and
getting a little more mature i'm
realizing how many people don't see
marketing the way i see it i see it as
oxygen
i see it as the thing that everybody in
this room should spend the majority of
their time on and most people when i
give this talk or have a meeting or have
navigated last 25 years are trying to
find time to get to marketing i'd rather
be great at contemporary marketing than
know how to balance my p l that's how my
brain thinks about it and so
as i'm going to go into this right now
there's only one thing that i know that
can double a person's business
without them making a significant change
in their product or service or having
some fortune like their local competitor
decided to retire like there's only one
thing and that is marketing and
marketing is incredibly confused with
sales
and i see it every day and i think
people have incredible comfort with
sales because they know what the roi is
in the very immediate the conversations
and the keynotes and the books that i
wrote you know seven ten years ago about
hey
print and radio and television the
things that i use to build my wine
business
they're declining in value you've got to
look at google adwords or email or you
know youtube that's becoming a
non-conversation i think i struggled to
think that people don't realize that
digital is a real serious form of
marketing what what is happening though
is as people have gone through that
transition
the land of navigating digital marketing
is incredibly vast and ridiculously up
and down you can waste an ungodly amount
of money doing digital marketing and get
nothing in return or you could spend a
stunningly low amount of dollars and get
very high upside and it just comes down
to the tactics and just understanding it
and i want to i want to spend some time
on that the other thing that i want to
spend time on is
is today is today's 16th tuesday yeah so
today was supposed to be the day my new
book came out if you guys can flash my
screen one more time so today was
supposed to be the day that my new book
came out uh 12 and a half
leveraging the emotional ingredients for
business success
i did a nft promotion in august that if
you bought 12 copies i would airdrop you
an nft
and sold 1.2 million copies which for
context makes it the most successful
book of all time
um or at least one of the top ten and um
and so they had to push it by two weeks
and it'll be coming out in two weeks but
it's just really fun timing that today
was supposed to be the day
because it's really the other thing i
desperately want to talk to you about
which is
my my navigating not only my own career
but i was an early investor in facebook
and twitter in uber in coinbase uh you
know i run an agency that's a you know
1800 person global company that works
with a ton of businesses
and something has really become very
clear to me again in this older state
which is
in business we don't really talk about
kindness
or empathy
or
compassion
or accountability or we don't talk about
soft skills
as a core we talk about it as like a
side dish
as a nice to have
and i think if you're very thoughtful
about what's going on in the world right
now and i don't mean the over coddling
and entitlement and that stuff i mean
people having options
as employees
you know creating continuity and
actually building something
very big instead of kind of okay or
solid
i think we need to start having an
advanced
dramatically different conversation on
what team building and leadership
actually is
and again i don't come from a foofy
place the way i call the way this book
was built was how i built my company
internally we call vaynermedia the honey
empire
right honey over vinegar
but the word empire is not a soft word
we're trying to build the biggest
company of all time and i think to do
that you need continuity based on
optimism
and growth not based on fear
you know and so
those are two things i really want to
double click on let's start with the
marketing thing because it's incredibly
practical for this room how many people
buy show of hands because i'm going to
navigate because i have a feel of the
mix how many people by show of hands
please raise them
are in the b to b business raise your
hands please hi please
thank you and b to c
great so predominantly b2b i'll jump on
both so b to b
how many people here are running
linkedin ads for their b2b business and
i mean ads in the feed not email things
that nature raise your hands just
curious great thank you so let's talk
about linkedin ads
this one this room is majority b2b
i i couldn't employ if if nothing from
this talk nothing from this talk
you remember except this one part
i hope this lands every company hence
person in this room
needs to be running three to four
original pieces of creative as ads on
linkedin a day
three to four linkedin ads a day
all different
videos pictures or words
all run as ads not your page and you
post and you organically just get
whatever linkedin puts it into the ethos
i mean you actually target
employees of companies or people's
titles
and you pay linkedin money in ad form to
convert the business goal that you want
disproportionately
in the last 18 months
the number one thing that i get emails
about with the content that i put out
around this
disproportionately this has been the
thing that i've been most emailed about
as a substantial game changer for b2b
companies
a couple things that are important about
this number one as we go through this
conversation or if we get into q and a
and go deeper and you sit there and say
you know what screw it i'm gonna follow
i'm gonna do it actually
first and foremost
you cannot hire your 23 year old niece
to do it
you can't hire a small
agency one person that you find you the
human in this room must
if you want the success from it but you
don't need to do anything like just to
really create the context but if you
would like your business to grow through
an arbitrage that is incredibly obvious
that will close
linkedin ads
are not as good right now as they were
24 months ago when i started this
conversation because more people have
come in and i'm sure everybody here is
going to understand the simple concept
of supply and demand
it's the same rodeo since myspace
thing happens myspace facebook twitter
youtube instagram snapchat tick tock
linkedin you it's all the same game
thing gets established people come on
board the early movers no different than
real estate development just with
content make content they extract the
biggest audiences
the big companies that i work with the
pepsi the budweiser's the fords they
wait they got to get their laws down
they got to figure it out they're scared
of it they wait eventually three years
in they get comfortable they start
throwing money at it it starts working
they start throwing real money at it all
of a sudden smbs mid-market companies
like ourselves don't get as much real
estate for free organically or the ads
cost too much against what we used to
spend for it it's the same show every
single time
the number one advertiser on television
in the first 10 years of television was
procter gamble that's why it's the
biggest consumer brands company in the
world the number one advertiser on
google adwords from 2001 to 2005 was
amazon it's why it's who it is
when there is an arbitrage of attention
the world changes
the only thing that connects every one
of our businesses here is the attempt to
get attention to tell somebody what we
want
or what we have and then hope the thing
happens that's how the world works
all the things that are happening
geopolitically and politically in our
country in the world it's just because
attention has gone from mainstream media
to social and new dynamics happen the
reason back to being a soviet boy the
reason when there's a coup in a country
that at the same time they go after the
palace they go to the newspaper and
radio and television station is because
communication and the ability to talk to
somebody and get their attention and
make the thing that you want to happen
is literally the only thing that matters
and so
the thought that so many people in this
room
don't think about that as the first
thing you do
even in parallel with the quality of
your product
though i did have a meeting last week
where i was very very very very very
underwhelmed with the product and the
person was very aggressive that they
needed my agency to be hired probably
because he subconsciously knew how bad
the product was and it finally pushed me
into the corner and i said sir with all
due respect i just want you to know one
thing we are the best marketing company
in the world which means the only thing
that's about to happen is we're gonna
speed up the world knowing that your
product's a piece of crap
so i'm like i think we should fix it
first and then we'll mark it
so
look
when i say it's the only thing that
matters of course the quality of your
product of course when i look around
this room there's a ton of you that have
substantial long-term relationships and
reputation in a bmv environment that is
absolutely driving your core business
my question is why people like to leave
upside on the table
when i get into these combos one on one
or on stage you know they're like gary
i'm good i don't need linkedin i'm like
the king of
dayton ohio i'm like that's nice carl
i'm like how much do you business do you
do 7 million i'm like what's wrong with
16
to me marketing is a conversation of
ambition
i understand that people don't want to
learn this i understand that you don't
want to spend 11 hours
running ads on linkedin tasting it
watching a bunch of videos reading a
bunch of stuff so that you can then hire
the person internally and know how to
judge if they're good at it the biggest
reason most companies
don't continue to do social media it's
because they hired somebody that sucks
at it and they don't know how to judge
it and then they decide it doesn't work
you know what else doesn't work a
basketball
a basketball does not work for me the
roi of a basketball for me has been
about negative ten thousand dollars
because i've torn both my meniscus
the roi of a basketball for lebron james
is a billion dollars
social marketing works at scale to
trillions of dollars
we just might have not figured out how
to make it work for ourselves
so for me
for this room there are two core things
that
really stand out one
is linkedin and you need to go pot
committed because again
what i've seen with the way ads are
being spent and the way the organic
reach is going down
how many people here use linkedin and
know what i'm talking about how it went
from just a recruiting tool to now
there's information content in there
just raise your hands i'm just curious
so you have a sense if you even sit for
a second think about if you've even
transacted or been affected by a piece
of content in linkedin just reverse
engineer yourself
it's there at scale for this room
the other thing that i think a lot of
people need to debate and this is for
the more ambitious and hungry the the
more on the offense
the concept of becoming the media
platform
instead of just an advertiser
meaning
actually starting a podcast or youtube
show around the expertise of the
business that you're in
now this gets really foofy for a lot of
people but it is absolutely in my
opinion the place that creates the most
guaranteed stability and growth of a
business the idea of becoming the
publisher not the marketer right there's
i was just with several people in the
back room and i was like look here's the
framework i live in i think most people
in this room and when i say this room i
mean america and i mean the eight
billion people on earth and whatever
percentage of those people are in
business most people are in sales
there's sales there's sales
organizations i'm sure if we're being
honest i could just see what you see by
some of those light head nods we are
sales organizations and that's great i
love sales when i was five years old
sales was my first business i walked
around edison new jersey i went into
people's yards ripped their flowers out
of the yard
ringed their doorbell and tried to sell
them back the flowers
i love sales
that's me at five i love sales
there's
remarkable sales
it's called marketing
it's super hard because spending money
on something that just branding doesn't
feel natural to an smb mid-market
company and even big companies don't
love it even though they allocate for it
because wall street makes them
branding
super important marketing it's the whole
actual game it's the thing that i want
you to get advanced at in linkedin it
will completely change your business for
real 20 40 80 growth it will it can it
does if you get good at it
the problem is most people a lot of
hands went up i feel like if this was a
class where we went through all the ads
without even knowing and a lot of hands
went up just because i know 98 of what i
see on linkedin is this so i'm making
the assumption that the math scales in
this room
the marketing
is actually just sales videos
or a sales flyer most people want to go
to marketing or really just doing sales
none of you want to see that nobody
wants an infomercial in their news feed
it's not value ad
period
but marketing is the second framework
much stronger than sales
in the medium and long term
harder to judge for people in the short
term which is why almost nobody does it
definitely not in the size companies
that are in this room for real do i love
linkedin so much when i force my dad to
do it and buy newspaper ads or radio or
direct mail was expensive
you can do linkedin for six thousand
bucks and get a real taste not make a
thirty thousand dollar commitment to a
full page ad newspaper so
marketing the third thing that i'm
talking to you about right now is the
concept of becoming the media company
what i've done with my career
the shows the content the vlogs
i don't make content
i just live my life we film it and then
we produce marketing for it
and so the concept of you actually i'll
give you a great example one more time
plea please me please b to b company
raise your hand
this is um this is my like number one
starting a podcast in your very narrow
niche even maybe your town
like you could talk about concrete in a
state or a town
narrow we're not trying to be the
letterman show here you're not trying to
win an emmy you're trying to get
business
starting a podcast
where you interview
the potential buyers that you're trying
to get business from
so this has been a monster hit for a lot
of people that have taken me up on this
you start a show
that's a podcast
where you talk about things in general
but the people that you email on
linkedin or on email to be guests are
the people that you actually want to buy
your product
this is really interesting human
psychology
the people you're emailing or calling or
trying to play golf with or have fake
dinner with or hitting up on linkedin to
do business with
are
often not interested
in what you're trying to do
and won't respond or say no
that same person
when you're saying you know so you're
trying to hit up barry barry want to go
golfing barry let me introduce you to my
guy barry can we get together barry's
not interested barry has his supplier
when you email barry and say barry would
you come on and talk about your amazing
career of the last 30 years on my
podcast barry's moonwalking to your
office
this last tactic
because i've thrown this out in my
content different interviews and such
has been
a
major win for some small b2b mid-sized
b2b companies
and i would highly highly recommend the
people in this room that have a little
gift of gab feel like they can do this
to really push themselves i'm aware
very aware a very introverted dad you
know like well actually he's not he's
come out of a shell but my mom's
introverted um in a lot of ways
i know that that last thing isn't for
everybody i know that you don't want to
put yourself on camera feels
uncomfortable it doesn't come natural
but please if you happen to be one of
the several dozens of people in here
that the thought of what i just said is
intriguing please push yourself it
really works
the the world is changing i don't have
to tell a single person here what i'm
trying to get everybody to understand is
take your real life and put it into your
business life here's what i mean by that
remember
remember how many of you promised me
that you would never get an iphone
because your blackberry was so awesome
and you needed to feel the buttons
just curious how many people here have a
blackberry right now
remember when you promised you would
never get a facebook account in 2012 11
10. we promise even for some of the old
school there's some old school cats and
here i see you
my favorite one was
when the cell phone started getting
traction in the late 90s all of my i've
got a beeper i don't need a cell phone
people in this room
this is what we do
even people that are progressive i spent
the last three years trying to convince
people that made real money and changed
their life on instagram to get tick-tock
accounts they're 26 and they said no
humans say no
many of you when you heard about bitcoin
no many of you when you're hearing about
nfts right now no it's just all no
it's exhausting and it makes no sense if
you're a business person
no is poison in business
quick question how many people here are
retiring in the next 10 years and before
you raise your hand i don't mean you're
going to have a huge year next year and
buy an island i mean you're old and
you're finished
raise your hands
raise it high
all right four
and you're definitely not in that crowd
you just wanted to raise your hand
four
my friends almost everything that
dominates our society right now netflix
most of the social networks
none of them existed 10 years ago
what i'm really trying to tell you in
this talk and by the way we're starting
to get that place so if you have any
question of every anywhere i'm going or
anything you know about me that you want
to ask questions please line up now
because i want to get into the q a
please do that while i'm wrapping up
here um
my friends i'm trying to prepare you
for what's coming
you guys hear about nfts and people
selling for 69 million dollars and
you're like scam beanie babies this and
that the blockchain is here
every contract
in the world in 15 years is gonna be on
the blockchain
it's how you're gonna do business
so what are you gonna do the same thing
you did with the internet which is fight
it until you succumbed to it and left
all that opportunity on the table
like how do we not see the patterns it
was one thing when the internet came and
we didn't have that and so the world was
one way and so it was very empathetic in
96 97 98 99 do you understand 1996 90 of
my conversations was trying to convince
somebody somebody would buy anything on
the internet
50 of my conversations were trying to
convince people that the internet wasn't
a fad do you remember some of you if you
paid attention to this when the stock
market crashed in 2000 with internet
stocks and every article was see the
internet's a fad
people don't like change
they don't like it we don't like it
the problem is you can do anything you
want in your personal life
i like when people like gary i just
don't get facebook i go that's nice stan
i understand that you don't get it how
about the fact that five trillion people
do
like i love when people make decisions
that are ideological on their human
level and then deploy them in their
business life
you don't like money
you don't want your family to be more
stable you don't want your business to
grow
you don't want somebody to come along
and use this stuff and put you out of
business all of those things i have a
funny feeling you are interested in you
may not want to dance on tick tock but
i'm not asking you to dance
i'm asking you to pay attention to
what's actually happening here
and we're just starting
technology doesn't care about your
feelings or how hard you worked to build
your little moat locally on reputation
it just comes along and destroys i spoke
at a conference ironically in orlando
seven years ago i was an early investor
in uber and ironically got booked they
didn't know for the limo and taxi
conference convention center to speak
but it was early uber it hadn't really
done its thing yet and i stood there and
i said
my friends i don't know if you know
about this and it started it was
happening in san francisco it just
opened in new york it was early and i
was like my friends i don't know if
you're paying attention but there's this
thing called uber
you know like i really think you might
want to like i think it's going to be
pretty disruptive i compared it to
amazon and bookstores this room laughed
me off the stage
first guy on the mic goes gary do you
know what politics is i'm like i sure do
he goes
we've got the
audacious we've got these local
authorities by the balls we have our
medallions
we contribute i'm like
that's nice i'm like do you know what
venture capital is
i'm like uber's gonna raise a billion
dollars in cash and i have a funny
feeling that's more than you have john
and i don't have to explain to all of
you what happened there
no matter what you think your moat is
and why not
i promise you there's one incredibly
important thing that i want to leave
with and then please please line up
because i want questions otherwise i'm
gonna have drock run around with the mic
your business
has a target on it
every entrepreneur is looking at every
localized business and trying to think
about scale
and they're going to use modern
marketing to create a moat just like
zillow did just like amazon did just
like i did with rezzy the restaurant app
and open table it's all going to be the
same game
the internet is where the real world is
we spend everyone's like the metaverse
and the vr and all this crazy stuff
we're living there now
do you know how many hours are spent
looking at this
do you understand
we live there now
this has happened whether you like it or
not
you've decided to be an entrepreneur and
a business owner or a senior executive
you decided
so that means you have to play on the
field in sports
it's obvious
when the greats i will never forget even
though i hated them because i'm a knicks
fan but paul pierce said something in
some interview
and i loved it he said something like
they asked him when he knew it was over
right when he had to retire and he said
something like
it was interesting it was just one
random game and this scrub
got by me
and i realized this guy would have never
gotten by me ever ever ever before and i
can't believe he dominated me like that
and i knew it was over
and it stuck with me in sports it's
obvious
in business it's not it's like whatever
that gas is that is coming out of your
car and then you just die in the garage
because you didn't know
that thing that's business it's
happening to you right now
but you just don't realize it and that's
because the technology lever especially
now
with what's going on with the blockchain
you have a blockchain and internet
happening at the same time
and what makes me sad
is
you can harness it
or you can put your head in the sand
it's just a very binary game
and i just don't know why
you wouldn't
and so that's that i didn't really get
to the culture part as much as i want to
but i'm going to sneak a little bit of
it in
all of that is fine and dandy
if you land three awesome people to run
your linkedin or one
it's all fine and dandy if you don't
know how to manage in 2021 you're gonna
lose
the options are ridiculous every 17 year
old that i know and i know a drilling of
them i have 10 million followers on tick
tock
every one of them have no interest in
going to college or working for anyone
because they can make a hundred thousand
dollars a year on tick tock
this isn't about these
gen zers and millennials being spoiled
this is called options
they're not lazy
they just don't want to work for you
like it's very important what this is
probably more important than what i
spent the most of my time on if you
don't realize that kindness and empathy
and compassion and all those things your
grandma tried to teach you are actually
becoming the core things you're gonna
need in your business to succeed
i love this new thing going on the great
resignation right and everyone's blaming
the government rightfully so like if you
pay people to stay home they're gonna
stay home like we understand that game
but let there be no confusion there's a
much more dangerous thing going on in
there because that check is gonna stop
what's underneath there
is options
right and i see a lot of head shaking
i'll tell you why
many of you have been baffled by your
kid or your kid's friend making real
money on tick tock and they're 14 and
you're like what the hell is going on
this is happening
and so look
when i talk like this i always laugh
because i can always hear my dad or
other people's voices in the crowd like
i'm very empathetic to somebody sitting
listening to me right now and saying you
know what
i'm retired
i get it because it's changing so fast
and hard it's like do i you know i've
gone hard for 50 years do i really want
a 30 year do i really
that's on you
but it doesn't mean it's not happening
and that's the point of this talk today
which is a lot's happening and i'd love
to get into details so i'll leave a lot
more for q a but thank you for having me
thank you
so i think a lot of people are going to
be very very motivated to start their
own podcast there's probably a handful
of people that try it there's going to
be a handful of people that are really
really good at it and then there's going
to be a bunch of people that probably
struggle that's right
that's right
that's right at what point do you have
to realize that you're approaching it
wrong have you had that about that
spider sense to figure out i need to
change my message how do i because you
know you need to keep doing it it's just
about happening
it's a really tough stick here we'll go
back and forth it's a really tough
question for me people always ask like
you know because i'm so infatuated with
tenacity and patience
infatuated like patience you know for
all my high energy patience has been the
foundation of my career
so i i'm always scared to give
a general answer to this question
because it's you know because i know
that there are many people that gave up
on their podcast and youtube show one
month before they were destined to click
it's happened
and
so
i i think the question is results and
time allocation right there's gonna be
people here if i'm looking at this crowd
i think i'm gonna get four people to
give it an at-bat one of those four
people is just gonna genuinely like it
and by the way on the podcast front
think about your interests i went very
narrow think about something like a
podcast called golf and business because
you just love golf and the show is just
interviewing people about how they do
business in golf golf business so like
you could like we're gonna play here a
little bit and go a little more detailed
but like
if somebody did it somebody heard that
and delilah that's actually perfect for
me and they do golf and business with
sally thompson she might just like it so
much
that it's almost doesn't matter it's my
entrepreneurial career what you know
when i was making 48 000 a year at 29
you know like or what i'm doing now it
all is the same
because i'm just in it for the game
and so for some people the podcast is
just gonna be an enjoyable hour of their
week and they won't even care if it's
business development for other people of
those four they're gonna do two episodes
they're not gonna get a lead and they're
gonna look at one of their teammates and
be like that gary he was full of crap
and just give up in two seconds
and then everything in between so
you know i think it's a very personal
answer
but i can tell you this the biggest
reason people fail with their podcast
when they hear what i say is because
they use it as a sales engine
and not just content and let the karma
and the brand fall where it may i do a
lot of business because
the first thing you said to me back
there is hey i'm a jets fan too because
of the way i do my content people
connect with me about my jets fandom
they connect with me about my jersey
kind of roots shoveling snow lemonade
my baseball cards my sneaker stuff you
know just like because i'm giving them a
lot of things to connect with because
i'm very comfortable in putting certain
things out there other things i'm not
you know this i don't put out any my
personal life you know if i have 12 and
9 year old nobody's ever seen them in
their lives so you're in control of what
you put out
but the podcast doesn't have to be it
can be incredibly narrow but as you just
saw with the idea i had and again some
of you care about sailing some of you
care about wine some of you can you can
really interject some of that by just
we're at literally tennis and business
sailing and like it's very strategical
but
traction
momentum always matters you know like i
promise somebody here does it and the
fourth guest is somebody they've been
trying to open as an account
and they do the podcast and they're
gonna get a beer afterwards and on the
way out that person looks at them from
the bar and says you know what let's
talk next week about the actual business
then they're going to go in a car and
say goddammit that gary's a genius
so either i'm the worst or i'm the best
but that's going to be based on the
variable of how good you are at it i
know it works i have too many examples
of it and when just so you know what the
way my career works from investing and
operating a marketing company i'm
talking about hundreds of thousands not
like three people there's no focus group
of one i would never tarnish my
reputation or my personal brand by
pontificating thesis on the focus group
of one or six this is scaled results
[Music]
you